hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in his work
concrete approaches to investigating the
ontological mystery one of the matters
that Gabrielle Marcel talks about quite
a bit is hope and you could actually see
a good portion of what he's doing in
this work as developing a interpretation
of faith hope and charity understood in
terms of fidelity hope and availability
he also talks about what he's doing as
providing an ontological interpretation
of hope that is a metaphysical
interpretation that is grounded in the
human condition which may be taking some
of its orientation from some
realizations or ideas originally
stemming from a Christian matrix but
going beyond that to reach to anybody
who is exhibiting this attitude and we
have to ask what what is hope is it just
a feeling that we have Marcel does not
think that that's what hope is although
it certainly does incorporate an
effective state in part because Hope
involves a sort of commitment on our
part
it is conative rather than merely
affective or emotional it also has a
a cognitive or thought component to it
as well there's a judgement being made
on a certain basic level by the person
who does hope and it's a continual one
that we're going to explore very quickly
with this this wonderful formula that
Marcel has for hope but before that we
should talk about why one might speak of
the mystery of hope so if we're using
mystery in the Marcel Yin sense where
it's a meta problem a problem that
encroaches upon its own data or a
problem in which the one who is you know
trying to solve the problem realizes
that he or she is already involved in
the problem there's a number of
formulations for what constitutes a
mystery what goes a little bit deeper
than a mere problem that can be solved
with a technique that can be dealt with
in a functional way if we understand
hope in that sense then hope is indeed
if not a mystery itself which I do think
arguably it is from of our salient
perspective then it certainly touches
upon all of the other mysteries and
Marcel will say at one point that we
when we look at the distinction between
hope and despair we see the distinction
or the borderline between the problem
and the mystery so we can think of
mystery and hope as tied together in
several different ways now we should
look at what Marcel actually has to say
about hope and he has this wonderful
formula it's been quoted by many people
as a matter of fact it's one of the
pieces that I think that many people who
don't read Marcel have in fact run
across and in endless quote sites so he
tells us that hope consists in asserting
that there is at the heart of being
beyond all data beyond all inventories
and all calculations
a mysterious principle in connivance
with me which cannot but will what I
will at least if what I will is really
worth willing and is in fact willed with
my whole being so there's a lot there
lot of different moving parts to this
definition or
characterization if you like and we
should look at each of them in turn
so notice to begin with he doesn't say
hope is a feeling he says her hope
consists in asserting or affirming
saying this is the case right judging it
involves a kind of commitment asserting
what asserting that there is at the
heart of being and we're going to talk
about this heart of being in just a
moment
a mysterious principle so there's
something in reality itself or in a part
of reality that really exists although
we may not be able to conceptualize it
adequately we may not be able to point
it out we definitely aren't going to be
able to scientifically measure it or
anything like that but there is
something there something real something
that has you might say wait a number
right in the Augustinian sense something
that can act and now notice what a
counter poses that too at the heart of
being beyond all data beyond all
inventories and calculations so what do
we mean by by that it's not that it's
it's totally disconnected from data or
the given you know the donating what
what is present to us what it is that we
can speak about objectively the things
that we can categorize put into
spreadsheets you know enter into certain
platforms relate in terms of means and
ends and causes and effects and all
these other things beyond inventories
and calculations beyond the sort of
cost-benefit analyses or beyond
probability estimates or beyond
statistical inferences beyond all of
that sort of stuff
which you know isn't nothing but beyond
all of that there's something else
there's something more and that's
something more he says is not just sort
of a when he uses the word principle
that might mislead you into thinking
it's
of ontological you know sort of
something like you know the law of
non-contradiction or you know some sort
of mind thinking itself or something
along those lines no it's something with
agency something that can relate to us
whatever that may be
now here's where it gets really
interesting he says that this is in
connivance with me it's working with me
it's helping me
it may not be helping me in the ways
that I asked it to or thought that it
would or you know was hoping for right
because sometimes you can you know ask
for something and it turns out that it's
really not to your benefit you were
misguided but it is in connivance with
me and he says which cannot but will
what I will now that makes it sound a
little bit like it's magic right there
is this wonderful principle out there
mysterious and it cannot will cannot but
will it has to will what it is that I
will so whatever it is that I want I
want a you know Mercedes Benz God will
give that to me all right if I just pray
hard enough or if I want you know this
this particular person for my mate
forever or to enjoy for one night or I
want to be able to eat as many cookies
as possible and never gain weight any of
those sorts of things you know hey
presto the mysterious principle will
make that happen no that is not at all
remotely what Marcel is saying this is
not the Christian prosperity gospel this
is not the new agey secret there's no
putting the positivity out there into
the universe and getting it back tenfold
there any of that other sort of nonsense
that's unrealistic stuff that's pie in
the sky that's not hope in the way that
Marcel talks about it why well notice
the other things that he says about will
he says that it has to be willed with my
whole being so there has to be a sort of
commitment or seriousness to this
this reminds me very much of a medieval
philosopher st. Anselm of Canterbury and
his discussion of willing he actually
coined a new term in Latin Vella means
to will and he coined a term para Vella
meaning to will perseveringly to
continue to will to use your Faculty of
will to will over and over and over
again it's very easy to have a desire or
a choice or a declaration that only
lasts for a moment I'm going to will to
go to the gym right I'm going to lose
all these these pounds and get a really
strong body and have my cardiovascular
system I also I sign up for the gym
that's an act of willing as well as an
action stemming from that act of willing
and now the question is do I go to the
gym or am i like so many other gym
members that the gyms make tons of money
off of who sign up and go once and never
show up again do I will consistently do
I make the choices that I need to make
oftentimes to the detriment of other
possible options right so willing with
my whole being that's part of it not
being distracted by other things but
this is even more important if what I
will is really worth willing willing and
mercedes-benz is not worth willing not
even if you're going to use it for
charity and drive old ladies to the
church or the election you know polling
place or to get groceries or something
like that because you can do that just
as well with a Honda Civic it's oh and
we can go on and on and on much of the
things that we will are not really worth
willing you know I don't need that
particular hamburger or that particular
plate of nachos right I don't need to
binge watch this particular show even if
it's the last season and I didn't get to
see the last episode those are those are
really not things that I have to expect
the you know this mysterious principle
to work with me on and if I do that's
because I'm I'm screwed up I have
somehow you know the wrong
is I have the wrong understanding of
things and if it doesn't cooperate with
me that's because I'm I'm you know
willing the stupid things that I
shouldn't be whittling right so hope
doesn't mean that you get to say Oh God
Oh universe oh whatever it happens to be
all mysterious principle give me the
stuff that I want there are conditions
for this and and Marcel is affirming
these he gives you an example of this he
says that to hope against all hope that
the person whom I love will recover from
an illness that is devouring her and
which is considered to be incurable is
to say it is not possible that I am
alone in willing her recovery it is
impossible that reality it's very depths
is hostile or only indifferent to what I
declare to be a good in itself and it
says it's useless to cite examples or
refer to cases of a sort intended to
discourage me beyond any experience
beyond all probabilities all statistics
I affirm a certain order will be really
established that reality is with me in
willing that it is so I am NOT just
wishing I am asserting notice the
difference they're willing and wishing
are not the same thing and he says this
is what I call the prophetic residence
of genuine hope and he says some people
might say well in the vast majority of
cases this is an illusion
it says besides the fact that is that
the essence of Hope to exclude mere
consideration of cases we must show
there's an ascending dialectic of Hope
now what is a dialectic the back and
forth where things are changed in the
process of their engagement with other
things without you know ceasing to be
hope your hope intensifies your hope
purifies your hope is as he says risin
to a transcendent level that is that
beyond all possible empiric disproof the
level of salvation as opposed to the
level of success no matter what form it
may assume so
hope itself isn't always exactly the
same thing there is like what he says
this ascending dialectic of hope
another thing that's that's
really important to point out is that he
thinks genuine hope he says is based on
something that does not depend on us
alone or even primarily with us so here
we go
he says genuine hope is based on what
does not depend on us genuine hope is
one whose wellspring is humility not
pride now what is humility is humility
walking along with your shoulders
hunched and saying oh I don't matter at
all
no that's despair and in Marcelle sense
genuine humility means recognizing who
and what you are to the best that you
can and how little agency or value you
have but also how much you have right
it's in between what Pascal call it's
the realization of what Paschal called
both the the greatness and the misery of
human beings the in-between of that
realizing we are what we are again to
bring up st. Anselm st. Anselm to find
humility as genuine knowledge of self
knowing what you in fact are and how you
fit in or fail to fit in right so
genuine hope is not going to be based on
a kind of pride fulness of oh I can do
anything I can accomplish anything if I
just put my mind to it and it's not even
you know this is like well the universe
owes me something so I'm gonna hope for
it and then the universe will grant it
to me
no it's realizing that if you you know
get what you want something else must
have done a good portion of the work and
this is really even if we don't think
about anything transcendent just think
about actually getting anything done
take any product my act of shooting this
video for you right now I hope that it's
going to be useful for some people well
that depends on so many things I didn't
make this chalkboard I didn't write this
book I didn't create this camera that
I'm filming with or these lights
I didn't do any of these things I am
just here helping you understand some
things that Marcel is saying and
fortunately YouTube exists to let these
videos go out there which is not even a
possibility 20 years ago and we could go
on and on and on nobody is self-made
that's part of the condition of humility
the last thing that's that needs to be
said about hope in the Marcela instance
is that he tells us it is not passive
acceptance resignation or inert hope
says some might say to me isn't what
you're attempting to justify
ontologically nothing else but a kind of
moral quietism meaning saying oh you
know I won't do anything I'll just hope
that things will go my way because I
can't really affect the universe or
myself or others I'll just have to hope
that things get better and he says that
well you know if that's the case isn't
action censured insofar as it implies a
self-confidence it's already akin to
pride or is an action of sort of
degradation and Marcel says you've
really misunderstood things if you see
it that way why he says the idea of
inert hope is a contradiction in terms
hope is not just waiting around it is
something that underpins and over arches
the action but which inevitably
degenerates or disappears when action
ceases he says I perceive hope as a
prolongation into the unknown of an
activity that is central that is rooted
in one's being
hence it's affinities not with desire
but with one's will hope is a matter of
willing so the will also carries within
itself a refusal to calculate
possibilities or at least a refusal to
be stopped by such a reckoning of
probabilities
so he says couldn't we define hope is an
act of will that applies itself to what
does not depend upon itself you might
say hope is an act of will that connects
the will to something more and beyond
its
with what really matters to the person
it refuses this is something that is
within the realm of our choice it
refuses either to calculate the
possibilities or if it does calculate
the possibilities and probabilities to
be stopped by these calculations and
probabilities to say oh well so I can
happen so therefore I will not hope at
all now we can close by saying should we
hope about everything Marcel doesn't go
into this but I think we can say that we
don't really have the capacity to hope
for every single thing all the time
because hope is an act of will so it
does demand work on our part so we
perhaps need to be thoughtful or careful
about what we're going to devote our
hope to and if we do that if we carry
out this reflection and then carry out
what Marcel thinks of as secondary
reflection that is reflection upon
reflection we might have a better sense
of priority when it comes to the things
that we devote our hope to so very
important concept for Marcel in this
essay concrete approaches to
investigating the ontological mystery
hope is at the center of the ontological
mystery and it is how we connect
ourselves to it
you